welcome everyone this is part four in
our series on methods and metrics we're
going to be talking about how we
organize data sets for the purposes of
conducting evaluations in nlp
let's begin with the classic train dev
test split this is a very common format
for data sets in our field especially
for the very large publicly available
ones uh and it's really good in the
sense that in releasing data sets with
these splits pre-defined we do ensure
some consistency across the different
evaluations that people run
it does the presuppose that you have a
fairly large data set because after all
right from the get-go you are setting
aside a whole lot of examples in the dev
and test splits that you can't use at
all to train your systems so even though
your system might benefit from those
examples you can't use them in that
context they can be used only for
evaluations you're just giving up a lot
of potentially useful examples
as we've discussed many times we're all
on the honor system when it comes to
that test set it's distributed as part
of the data set but it has a privilege
status
the test set can be used only once all
of system development is complete
and then you do a single evaluation on
the test set and report that number
completely hands off
this is vital for our field because it's
the only way that we can even hope to
get a true picture of how our systems
are truly generalizing to new examples
that said
the downside of having pre-defined train
dev test splits is that inevitably
everyone is using those same dev and
test sets
and what that means is that over time as
we see consistent progress on a
benchmark task
we're taking that same measurement on
that same test set and it can be hard to
be sure whether we're seeing true
progress on the underlying task
or the result of a lot of implicit
lessons that people have learned about
what works and what doesn't for that
particular test set and that's true even
if everyone is obeying that honor code
and do it using the test set only for
truly final evaluations nonetheless
information can leak out and we might
start to mistake true progress um when
we're actually just seeing progress on
that particular test set and i think the
only way that we can really combat this
is by continually setting new benchmark
tasks for ourselves um with new test
sets so that we see how systems perform
in truly unseen environments
as you leave nlp it's common to find
data sets that don't come with that
predefined train dev test split and that
poses some methodological questions for
you this is especially true for small
public data sets that you see out there
this poses a challenge for assessment
for robust comparisons you really have
to run all your models
using your same assessment regime that
is the same splits
and that's especially important if the
data set is small because of course in a
small data set you're probably going to
get more variance across different runs
and this can make it really hard to
compare outside of the experimental work
that you're doing if someone has
published the results of some random 70
30 train test split
unless you can reconstruct exactly the
splits that they used it might be
unclear whether you're doing a true
apples to apples comparison so that's
something to keep in mind and it does
mean that if you can for your own
experiments you might impose a split
right at the start of your project this
is probably feasible if the data set is
large and what it will mean is that you
have a simplified experimental setup
and you have to do
less hyper parameter optimization just
because there are fewer moving parts in
your underlying experimental setup
it does presuppose that you have a
pretty large data set because as i said
before you have to give up a whole bunch
of examples to dev and test
but it will simplify other aspects of
your project if it's feasible
for small data sets though imposing a
split might leave too little data
leading to highly variable performance
and in that context if that's the kind
of behavior that you observe
you might want to move into the mode of
cross-validation
so cross-validation in this context we
take a set of examples say our entire
data set and we partition them into two
or more train test splits
when you might do that repeatedly and
then average over the results of
evaluations on those splits in some way
to give a holistic summary of system
performance and in that way even as
those numbers vary they might have a lot
of variance we're still getting in the
average we hope a pretty reliable
measure of how the system performs in
general on the available data and i'm
going to talk about two ways to do cross
validation each with its own strengths
and weaknesses let's begin with what
i've called random splits here so under
the random splits regime you take your
data set
and let's say k times
you shuffle it
and you split it and you have t percent
per train and then probably the rest
left out for test
and on each one of those splits you
conduct some kind of evaluation
get back your metrics and then at the
end of all these k evaluations you
probably average those metrics in some
way to give a single summary
number for system performance
in general but not always when we do
these splits we want them to be to be
stratified in the sense that the train
and test splits should have
approximately the same distribution over
the classes uh in in the underlying data
but i've been careful to say that this
is not always true there could for
example be context in which you would
like your test set to stress test your
system by having a very different
distribution maybe an even distribution
or one that's heavily skewed towards
some of the smaller but more important
classes
and that will pose a challenge for train
test regimes because the system's
experiences at train time will be
different in this high level
distributional sense from what it sees
at test time but that of course might be
part of what you're trying to pursue as
part of your overall hypothesis
the trade-offs for this kind of
cross-validation the good is that you
can create as many splits as you want
without having this impact the ratio of
training to testing examples right
because
k times we're just going to do a random
split and it can be consistent that we
do independent of k
70 train 30 test or 50 50 or whatever we
decide we want um that's independent of
the number of splits that we set
the bad of this of course is that
there's no guarantee that every example
will be used the same number of times
for training and for testing and for
small data sets this could of course be
a concern because you might be
introducing unwanted correlations across
the splits uh in for example never
having certain hard examples be part of
your test set just as a matter of chance
so that's something to keep in mind but
of course for very large data sets it's
very unlikely that you'll be susceptible
to the bad part of this and then you do
get a lot of the benefits of the freedom
of being able to run lots of experiments
with a fixed train test ratio
and of course as usual scikit has a lot
of tools to help you with this so i've
just given some classic examples down
here from the model selection package
you might import shuffle split
stratified shuffle split and of course
train test split is a useful utility for
very quickly and flexibly creating
splits of your data and i make heavy use
of these throughout my own code
the second regime for cross-validation
that i'd like to discuss is k-folds
cross-validation here the method is
slightly different we're going to take
our data set and split it into three
folds in this case for three-fold
cross-validation you could of course
pick any fold number that you wanted
and then given this three-fold
cross-validation we're going to conduct
three experiments one where fold one is
used for testing
and two and three are merged together
for training
a second experiment where we hold out
fold two for testing and the union of
one and three is used for training and
then finally a third experiment where
fold three is used for testing and folds
one and two are concatenated for the
train set
the trade-offs here are slightly
different from the trade-offs for random
splits so the good of this is that every
example
appears in a train set exactly k minus
one times and in a test set exactly once
we have that guaranteed in virtue of the
fact that we use a single split over
here to conduct our three experimental
paradigms
the bad of this of course can be really
difficult the size of k is determining
the size of the trained test split right
just consider that for three-fold
cross-validation we're going to use 67
of the data for training
and 33 for testing
but if three experiments is not enough
if we want 10 folds the result of that
will be that we use 90 of our data for
trading and 10 for testing and the
bottom line is that those are very
different experimental scenarios from
the point of view of the amount of
training data that your system has
and probably the variance that you see
in testing because of the way you're
changing the size of the test set
whereas for the random splits that we
just discussed we have an independence
of the number of folds and then the
percentage of train test examples that
we're going to have and that can be very
freeing especially for large data sets
where the value up here in the good is
really less pressing
and again scikit-learn has lots of tools
for this i've actually just given a
sample of them here you have k-fold
stratified k-fold and then cross-val
score is a nice raptor utility that will
again give you flexible access to lots
of different ways of conceptualizing
cross validation